qualcuno potrà domandarsi ieri io ho
parlato di uguaglianza di libertà va
bene un po di filosofia politica
avventurando mi anche sul terreno
religioso sono un economista
almeno questa è stata la mia qualifica
accademica
questa sera vengo a parlarmi di
democrazia che c'entra certamente quei
temi di ieri ma lo faccio in una classe
chiave diversa essenzialmente
descrittiva
può suscitare qualche sospetto che spero
di fugare io penso comunque che
occupandosi di una materia si imparano
degli strumenti si acquisiscono delle
agilità mentali delle capacità di
collegare le cose del mettere a fuoco
individuare la natura dei problemi che
consente anche a diciamo uno che non
parte come specialista ma se lavora sul
serio almeno di provarci e dire qualche
cosa di interessante il tema di questa
sera è che anche il titolo del libro e
geografia della democrazia cioè
praticamente di individuare
quali e dove sono quanti quali e dove
sono i paesi democratici
oggi come oggi dove quanti erano un
certo tempo fa
i quali caratteristiche ha avuto diciamo
questo passaggio questo processo
il primo punto da chiarire è
cosa intendiamo per democrazia di qua
non sia un concetto assai complesso e
l'uso che ne faccio io è molto limitato
anche per dovendo coprire cioè la
rassegna che io faccia guarda tutti i
paesi del mondo quindi diciamo quanto
più vasta e l'area che si copre tanto
più essenziale e in qualche modo anche
superficiale devono essere i tratti che
si colgono allora qui tutorio di è
democrazia di stati nazionali o salta
completamente il problema della
democratizzazione di entità
sovranazionali degli stati nazionali che
hanno dei territori ben definiti delle
popolazioni degli organi di governo
sugli stessi
inoltre è una democrazia di tipo
essenzialmente formale e procedurale
sostanzialmente una democrazia formale
una democrazia in cui sono rispettate
libertà civili e politiche in cui c'è
pluralità di partiti c'è libertà di
stampa
c'è qualche modo da cosetta rule of law
cioè
rapporti sono regolati da leggi e gli
organi politici dotati di potere
politico sono eletti regolarmente
attraverso elezioni libere e regolari e
ripetute esiste un certo bilanciamento
di poteri
questa nozione di democrazia formale in
qualche modo lo scheletro possiamo
paragonarlo allo scheletro ora lo
scheletro di un di un individuo di un
animale ci dice molto ma non tutto
possiamo dire che in assenza di
scheletro con uno scheletro deforme
l'animale o non c'è o è mal fatto però
anche con uno scheletro regolare molto
rimane ancora
indeterminato quindi diciamo la qualità
di stati che soddisfano i requisiti
formali della democrazia la qualità del
loro sistema politico delle politiche
producono della vita che si sviluppa
all'interno di essi può essere assai
varia
oggi in italia ci lamentiamo molto del
nostro sistema politico e giustamente e
qui ecco
e giustamente però nessuno mette in
dubbio il carattere democratico che
soprattutto una celebre frase di
churchill che volete sei stato detto che
è stato detto spesso che la democrazia è
il per la peggior forma di governo ad
eccezione di tutte le altre che sono
state provate sembra così un paradosso
ma è vero è facilissimo ogni volta che
si affronta un problema si vedono che
spesso le democrazie sono lo affrontano
male è facile immaginare degli altri
sistemi politici che sulla cosa
specifica farebbero meglio però in
realtà la l'alternativa complessiva è
peggiore allora la nazione uno dei pregi
dal punto di vista soprattutto del mio
studio di questa nozione formale o
procedurale della democrazia che si basa
su elementi che sono oggettivamente
osservabili cioè quello che ha detto
elezioni regolari proprietà di partiti
eccetera eccetera si può vedere dove ci
sono e dove non ci sono e si possono
fare anche delle gradazioni della misura
qui ci sono pienamente sviluppati la
meno non ho fatto io ho lavorato su
materiali sono diverse istituzioni la
principale di questa dal nome di freedom
house è un americano che ha
studiato il fenomeno dal 1882 fino ad
oggi pubblica regolarmente delle tabelle
in cui sono dati punteggi sintetici per
i diversi indicatori di ogni paese viene
dato registi analitici per categorie
ricorsi a sintetici e accompagnati poi
anche da dei testi brevemente
descrittivi freedom house usa tre
categorie dei paesi che chiama liberi
semi liberi e non liberi io nel mio
libro ne ho
articolati di più non trasformata in sei
propri quel che ci interessa
sostanzialmente io ho distinto tra le
democrazie quelle che freedom house
chiama democrazia quello che chiamo
normali che sono le migliori e
democrazia e di bassa qualità che sono
pur sempre democrazie ma hanno degli
score più bassi
allora sulla base di questi possiamo
vedere come dice o si tratta di dati
osservabili e
ecco questo è la distribuzione
geografica
delle democrazie qui non c'è la
distinzione tra quelle di loro che io
chiamo normali e quelle di bassa qualità
nel
1972 vedete grandi fuori c'è l'area
sostanzialmente nato fuori di lì ove
paesi giappone india e alcuni paesi
sudamericani
pochi
2012 lo scenario è questo qui dunque
allora in verde scuro ci sono quelle
della figura precedente in verde chiaro
sono le nuove le democrazie nuove i
paesi che si sono democratizza t e in
arancione quelli che invece hanno
cessato di essere democratici magari
scendendo non necessariamente attraverso
la trasformazione in brutali dittature
ma certamente attraverso uno scadimento
della democrazia
ora questo quello che io ho fatto e se
una forma di diciamo uno studio di un
empirismo molto elementare la bacone
taboulé presenza e al semplice
democrazia si democrazia no
eventualmente che magari in mezzo e
vedere
individuare una serie di altri fenomeni
correa che pochi sono in qualche modo
anche loro osservabili e correlabili a
complementare a queste come dicevo le
sono altri due qui abbiamo la giunta
prevalente sulle sottrazioni dalle
democrazie qui è difficile contarlo ma
il numero delle democrazie all'incirca
raddoppiato
questo è un fenomeno
in una particolare queste sono le quelle
che usiamo le democrazie normali diciamo
quelle compiute eccetera che hanno si
distribuiscono in modo abbastanza
curioso ma che ha un suo significato
sono essenzialmente confinano tra di
loro o sono separate dal mare e il mare
è un confine aperto è un canale di
possibile comunicazione anzi è difficile
bloccare il mare più facile bloccare un
confine terrestre e sono hanno alcune
caratteristiche tra l'altro sono
politicamente affini sono legate anche
in genere vari tipi di trattati
economici o anche militari l'area
superiore prevalentemente formata da
paesi che sono nella nato e alcune di
quelle il verso il versante pacifico
sono il paese il sistema del dell'anzhi
giappone eccetera del l'elemento
strategico militare anche la sua
importanza perché la democrazia si
confrontano con lennon democrazie in
modi che non sono sempre troppo pacifici
quali sempre stando a questo livello di
assoluta generalità e direi quasi di
superficialità si possono individuare
alcune classi di fenomeni che
sono frequentemente non sistematicamente
associati con la democrazia che quindi
fornire può fornirci degli embrioni di
spiegazioni del perché la democrazia c'è
o non c'è e delle indicazioni
riguardo al suo possibile
affermarsi fondamentalmente ne ne avrei
individuati tre nel libro mio se ne
prendono in considerazione del maggior
ma per dare un po il senso della
globale della cosa sono 1 il grado di
sviluppo economico
farò vedere
facciamo un passo indietro complementare
alla distribuzione delle democrazie che
confinano tra di loro e quindi in
qualche modo a confinare fate un paese
con fini con una democrazia tende ad
aumentare la sua priorità che sia
democratico o che se non lo è si
democratizzi ma ho anche dagli zoccoli
duri di resistenza e qui li vediamo i
principali sono le tre aree colorate
sono quelle in cui la democrazia non è
penetrata e sono quell'area marone là
sopra sono quei paesi poi tutti i paesi
ex comunisti in quali il comunismo non
era stato semplicemente portato da
un'occupazione straniera come
nell'europa dell'est ma in cui era in
qualche modo autoctono la cina la russia
alcune repubbliche sovietiche
vietnam la cambogia eccetera quella
curiosa isola bianca là dentro e la
mongolia che stranamente passa i test di
una democrazia seppure di bassa qualità
questo a dimostrare che nulla è diciamo
non esistono né ostacoli nei fattori
favorevoli
assoluti la gra è questa l'area verde e
l'area
arabo islamica direi islamico con la
prevalenza del arabo islamico anche se
si comprendono anche afghanistan e
pakistan con che certamente però poi
dopo al problema religioso che non
esclude del tutto la rende incompatibile
la islam e democrazia però l'islam medio
orientale nord africano si è rivelato
abbastanza impermeabili lo stesso
diciamo è sembrato un paio d'anni fa che
con le primavere arabe queste
potesse venire meno in qualche modo è
stato un fenomeno certamente
significativo però fino da nessuna parte
è ancora arrivato a compimento dato
pensare che certamente i fermenti ci
sono anche lì è la terza area è l'aria
africana dove il principale fattore di
ostacolo e l'arretratezza o addirittura
la non piena esistenza degli stati che
la democrazia è un fenomeno di stati
nazionali occorre che la condizione
perché uno status democratizzi che sia
uno stato effettivamente funzionante
cioè che il governo abbia il controllo
completo del territorio che non ci siano
non sia in mano a bande che
in africa insieme a tanti
questo fattore gioca oltre il fatto che
lì è una zona compatta di autocrazia ed
è un paese che sta in mezzo ad l
autocrazia ha certamente delle
difficoltà
democratizzarsi allora dicevo gli altri
fattori 1 lo sviluppo economico e questo
è la prossima tabella qui allora che
sono raggruppate se guardate il
i colori rappresentano il verde sono le
democrazie il quel verde chiarissimo le
semi democrazie il rosso le autocrazie e
sono i quattro gruppi sono i livelli di
reddito pro capite
a parità di potere d'acquisto questo
allora sopra 10 mila tra 5 e 10 tra 1500
e
sotto mille è evidente che c'è una forte
correlazione cioè nel paesi sopra con un
reddito pro capite sopra 10 mila sono
per la 82 per cento democratici e quelli
non democratici lì dentro sono tutti i
paesi produttori di petrolio
il petrolio è in sé un ostacolo per
motivi che adesso non posso sviluppare
allo sviluppo della democrazia se un
paese democratico scopre il petrolio
come la norvegia niente di male anzi
tanto meglio se un paese
autocrati su facebook pratico si scopre
il petrolio è molto più difficile che
l'autocrazia scompaia quindi vediamo
come la la percentuale delle
democrazie tenda a né decisamente a
salire mentre quella delle autocrazie
abbastanza stabile e quella delle demo
delle semi democrazia ha un andamento
strano altra scende fino a ridursi
sensibilmente
allora da questo quadro uno sarebbe
tentato a essere ottimista di and bess
come il mondo economicamente sta
sviluppando e oggi tra l'altro una larga
parte dei paesi poveri si stanno
sviluppando
economicamente ha dei ritmi abbastanza
rapido di più o meno andranno dentro la
non è detto che sia che sarà così perché
molti paesi oggi democratici lo erano
già quando erano ancora poveri gli stati
uniti sono materializzati quando erano
un paese ancora arretrato quindi il
progresso economico ci dà delle
indicazioni incoraggianti ma non
sufficienti un altro fattore
significativo è la religione la
democrazia sia affermata dapprima in
paesi protestanti si riteneva difficile
che si sviluppasse in paesi cattolici
poi lo ha fatto impetuosamente oggi in
qualche modo vediamo dal protestantesimo
il cattolicesimo oggi in larga
maggioranza democratico il cristianesimo
ortodosso anche in zone buddismo
confucianesimo induismo anche lo stesso
islamismo esistono anche casi sono in
ordine decrescente di
democraticità però anche nel mondo
islamico di alcune democrazie si sono
affermate un altro fattore significativo
che si accompagna ho fatto vedere come
il confinare la vicinanza fisica
favorisca la democratizzazione anche il
grado di integrazione economica
certamente favorisce entrare in rapporto
con le democrazie comporta già un certo
grado di democratizzazione perché per
scambiare trattare liberamente con un
paese bisogna fare propria anche
conferire ai propri cittadini alle
proprie imprese dei gradi libertà che
gli consentano di
comunicare un aspetto significativo
delle democrazie e quella della
cosiddetta pace democratica le
democrazie non si sono mai fatte guerre
tra di loro che se un fatto puramente
empirico prima o poi sarà smentito però
non si sono sono state studiate raccolte
tutte le coppie di stati che si sono
trovate in guerra l'uno con l'altro gli
schieramenti opposti non si è mai
verificato il caso che paesi democratici
si trovassero su due
versanti diversi
ripeto è una regolarità forte non è una
legge ferrea e prima o poi se la
democrazia vivrà abbastanza a lungo come
io pero qualche eccezione si verificherà
per la certamente le probabilità di
conflitto diminuiscono sensibilmente non
è che la democrazia siano
necessariamente pacifiche hanno fatto
tante tantissime guerre ma le hanno
fatte in genere con non democrazie
finale